this week in our school matter series we
are looking at mental and physical
health issues in schools from nurse
shortages to the pressures of sports
today we are taking you inside Alabama
schools a new statewide program will
soon give high schools access to an
opioid overdose reversal drug called
Knox alone naloxone rather the state is
the first in the nation to Train
administrators coaches and even teachers
to use the life-saving drug now
previously only certified nursers nurses
could administer it Manuel Bojorquez
went to Montgomery Alabama to show us
how this new initiative works what
you're watching is actually a training
drill a group of staff members here in
Montgomery are acting out a scenario of
an opioid overdose the goal is to learn
how to administer an overdose reversal
drug called naloxone the auto-injector
looks more like a cigarette box than a
drug that could save a life
very nice job guys I spent 10 years in a
public school as a principal and it's
very common to be walking down the hall
and come upon a situation like this I
mean you're learning possibly how to
save a life here so yes the woman giving
out instructions is state nurse
administrator Jennifer Ventress so we
developed this training to teach people
in the absence of a nurse how to give
this drug so a principal a coach
possibly a teacher exactly a task Oh
we'll get one of these Ventris later
gave us a demo with an empty injector so
we're gonna pull this off we've not had
this happen in our schools and we're
thankful for that but should it happen
we want to be prepared
preparation is also underway about three
hours north near Huntsville Alabama the
drug is important because it works fast
we're trainings that started at Sparkman
high just last month we were there when
11th graders Bella Powell and Jackson
Mays first learned how this device works
it's very similar to an EpiPen so it's
relatively easy to use which is good
more than 400 opioid-related overdoses
were reported in the state of Alabama in
2017 according to the CDC the state
ranked highest in the nation in opioid
prescriptions back in 2015 the state is
set to have more prescriptions than the
number of people the drug costs one
hundred seventy eight dollars per dose
all paid for by a grant meaning no cost
to taxpayers
school officials say this is not only
for the safety of students they say this
can be used on anyone who comes to
campus for any of a number of events
anything from basketball games to
recitals we're one of the top states
that have a opioid abuse Eric Mackey is
Alabama's state superintendent schools
have so many needs right now teacher pay
supplies why has this become a priority
well school health our student health is
a priority and people could say well you
ought to be investing your money just in
textbooks and teachers and academic
things but but there we know good
academic outcomes if there's not healthy
students in scope
he was absolutely easing while he was in
school the opioid epidemic hit close to
home for Laurie Roberts almost five
years ago when her oldest son will
overdosed on the back porch of their
house it is truly one of the most
painful things and hardest things that
ever ever gone through will became
addicted to opioids during his sophomore
year of high school
after his wisdom tooth removal but he
was lucky he survived I have been
blessed so far that my son is still
alive and as a parent of a child who is
in recovery you learn that it is a every
day the rest of my life worried for CBS
this morning
Manuel Bojorquez Montgomery Alabama you
know you think about that too way you
learn in school you can use later in
life too
you never know where you're gonna be
and tomorrow in our school matter series
we will talk to former NFL quarterback
Jesse Palmer about the mental and
physical benefits of kids athletics and
we will be right back
[Music]